le coc vide n'a pas seulement entamé le
portefeuille des français et leur moral
la crise sanitaire a également accru une
sensation d'insécurité matérielle chez
nos concitoyens les résultats d'une
étude conjointe de l'ifop de la
fondation jean jaurès et de lagence du
don en nature réalisée sur deux mille
personnes viennent de sortir l'objet de
l'étude était la précarité matérielle
les auteurs concluent que les personnes
les plus modestes ne souffre pas que de
pauvreté mais aussi de se sentir à part
des classes et ceci génère chez eux des
sentiments de frustration d'injustice de
colère ou de résignation selon les cas
considérons le contexte de l'étude elle
vise à comprendre les impacts de la
précarité des français et en cette
période de crise sanitaire
la fragilité est encore plus manifeste
en effet 36 % des français ont vu leur
situation financière se dégrader depuis
le début de la crise du coronavirus ces
résultats sont à rapprocher de ceux
d'une étude de l'insee faisant valoir
que près d'un français sur cinq se
trouvent en situation de privation
matérielle et sociale et ce malgré les
nombreuses aides et prêts proposés par
le gouvernement aux entreprises qui
n'ont pas suffi à consolider la
situation de tous les plus touchées les
jeunes les travailleurs précaires comme
les auto-entrepreneurs les intérimaires
et les ménages modestes leurs soucis
financiers entraînent un changement de
leurs habitudes de consommation
ils ont davantage recours aux hard
discount attendant les promotions sur
les produits qu'ils convoitent et
surtout il se prive de produits non
alimentaires essentiels jusqu'à quatre
fois par mois comme par exemple des
objets numériques ordinateurs téléphones
ou encore vêtements alors que ces objets
leur seraient utiles pour chercher un
emploi ou pour tout simplement
travailler ils sont dans une logique de
renoncement d'auto privations et cette
austérité laisse des traces en plus de
les handicaper elle génère chez eux un
sentiment d'éviction social ces
personnes en difficultés n'ont pas
recours au troc ou prêts ou l achat de
seconde main qui pourrait mettre fin à
une partie des soucis liés au manque de
produits car ils ont envie d'acheter
neuf pour se sentir comme tout le monde
cela finalement vient bien en écho avec
les demandes initiales des gilet jaune
qui plaidait pour conserver leur pouvoir
d'achat d'ailleurs un segment de l'étude
examine leur rapport à l'achat de
produits neufs légers les jeunes
interrogés expliquent qu'un objet peu
représentés pour une consommation
similaire à celle de la majorité des
ménages français et la possibilité de
pouvoir consommer digne ces pourcentages
sont bien plus élevés que pour
l'ensemble de la population
mais d'ailleurs quels sont les impacts
générés par cette frustration ce
sentiment d'être à la marge d'être
laissé sur le bord de la route se
traduit-elle dans un engagement
politique militant syndical pas
nécessairement puisqu'ils ne sont que
21% et s'être engagé dans un mouvement
en revanche l'étude note que les
français interrogés se sentent gilet
jaune à 16% ou les soutiennent à 43% et
que les gilet jaune eux-mêmes vivent des
sentiments de frustration d'injustice et
de colère bien plus marquée que dans la
population générale il auteurs statut
que lutter contre la précarité
matérielle ce n'est pas simplement
fournir des produits de première
nécessité
c'est préserver ou redonner une place
dans la société des conclusions de bon
sens mais qui n'ont pas jusque là
trouver beaucoup d'écho si l'on en juge
par les décisions prises par le
gouvernement pour restaurer dans leur
dignité et gilet jaune ou assimilés